[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir aux
sujets qui font l'actualité
actuellement 40% des appareils
électriques et électroniques sont
réparés l'état souhaite atteindre 60%
d'ici cinq ans et depuis le 1er janvier
5 catégories de produits sont concernés
par un indice de réparabilité alors
bonne ou mauvaise idée
première étape pour lutter contre le moc
et ce pillage on en parle avec nos
invités
laurence attrait et jean paul bradley
vous êtes co fondateur de ré partout et
compagnie qui propose des ateliers pour
remettre en état des objets du quotidien
bonjour bonjour
philippe lioret vous êtes le président
de l'antenne locale de ufc que choisir
bonjour bonjour eric gatineau vous êtes
le directeur d'envy attrape un réseau
d'insertion professionnelle autour de
l'économie circulaire bonjour bonjour
est la figure et je le disais tout à
l'heure seulement 40% des appareils sont
réparés aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est lié
à une méconnaissance des possibilités de
réparation ou une facilité alors entre
guillemets en fonction des moyens
financiers qu'ont pu la voir a changé
d'appareil à d'éviter le je pense que
notre mouvement il faut au moins la
vérité des consommateurs et qui
forcément qu'un achat actuellement à
quand une hésitation en ce qui concerne
votre vie de ces appareils
donc c'est pour ça qu'au niveau de ses
quelque chose de rentabilité très
longtemps pour qu une meilleure
promotion qui sera faite auprès des
consommateurs
nous c'est pareil et saluer eric catinot
à a envie les salariés réparé de
l'électroménager est ce que vous recevez
des appareils qui sont difficiles à
réparer soi des appareils qu'ils sont
averses parfois faciles à réparer ces
bonnes nouvelles qui seraient qui sont
jetés et qui sont destinés à la
destruction quand on arrive à réparer
facilement
on reçoit une partie des appareils qui
sont pas réparables techniquement soit
vraiment trop trop anciens soient tous
animés et puis entre les deux on a des
appareils qui sont techniquement
réparable et pour lequel la logique
économique à la fois pro consommateurs
et pour pour l'opérateur se pose donc
quand le prix la réparation par rapport
à au prix d'un appareil de remplacement
est trop élevé le choix se pose pour
consommateurs
et puis de l'autre côté la logique
économique peut aussi d'amener des
combats des contrats d une limite à la
réparabilité des des produits donc on a
ces différentes catégories de produits
quatre figures laurence attrait quand on
vient vous voir pour des ateliers
est ce que vous dites oui on peut tout
réparer alors nous on dit on peut tout
diagnostic et c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose en fait qui compte c'est
quand même le l'étape importante c'est
vraiment le diagnostic en fait on prend
en charge en convient mais l'objet avec
la personne qui nous apporte l'objet et
on prend le temps en fait de regarder de
discuter avec la personne pour essayer
d'identifier en e-mail l'origine de la
panne et ensuite on regarde au niveau
des différentes étapes ce qu'il est
possible de faire dans temps imparti que
nous on intervient dans différentes
structures et du coup on n'a pas
forcément non plus à disposition tout
l'espace et le temps nécessaires alors
l'info depuis le 1er janvier 2021 cinq
catégories de produits sont concernés
par un indice de réparabilité il y a les
lave-linge les téléviseurs les
smartphones les ordinateurs portables et
les tondeuses à gazon
alors avant de développer le principe de
cet indice philippe le ray pour ffc que
choisir est ce que c'est une bonne idée
ah oui
de haan je dirais que lorsqu'on achète
un produit généralement les vendeurs
proposent la télé et sur deux ans il ya
un ces deux environnements sont proposés
notre patience complémentaires et sait
jamais après les autres et notamment sur
ses appareils d'art et je pense que
comme les machines à laver par exemple
on a souvent constaté ce genre de
problème donc ces bonis sentiment que
vous partagez les gatineau j'imagine que
ça évitera que certains électroménager
soient jetés alors qu'eux ils peuvent
continuer à fonctionner oui complètement
tu as tout ce qui va dans le sens d'une
meilleure information du consommateur et
qui l'amène à réfléchir à la durabilité
de ces équipements
c'est quelque chose qu'on soutient dans
le réseau envie c'est de combat
quotidien de deux de nos associations
donc oui c'est une bonne idée
elle aura un prolongement avec indices
de durabilité qui sera entendu
bon c'est pour 2024 et c'est pour nous
c'est une étape importante
on en est au début et et on sera là on
sera très très attentif à son
application et à ses effets en espérant
que ça entraîne une plus grande durée
d'usagé des appareils jean paul bradley
vous proposez donc des ateliers de
réparation pour toute personne qui est
intéressé est-ce que savoir qu'un
appareil est plus facilement réparable
va être plus intéressant
oui c'est une chose mais de grandes
difficultés du comics et qu' il a appris
à jeter donc même si on sait que c'est
réparable qui atelier de réparation
on se rend compte que les personnes
oublient ne sont pas des marches
jusqu'au bout
c'est vraiment ils ont un réflexe c'est
très bête de jeter et de racheter les
tounes je t'aime le cas d'un bricoleur
qui a besoin d'une perceuse début du
week-end sa perceuse tombe en panne
selon les pannes sont facilement
réparable mais il a besoin de terminer
ce chantier il va racheter une perceuse
naissance un passeur il va la payer même
si c'est que c'est réparable
parce qu'il est gatineau justement sur
cette facilité à à changer facilement de
produits on sait on connaît cette
fameuse abama garantie terminé comme par
hasard ça tombe en panne
mais est ce que justement vous voyez des
gens venir se renseigner vous il était
prévu de vous il prévoyait pardon de
vous donner un produit finalement vous
le faites réparer juste seulement
réparer ils repartent avec oui ça fait
partie de la démarche d'accueil en
magasin notamment en fait ça fait 36 ans
que quand vignes
reddy's donc rénove reconditionne répare
des appareils qu'ils étaient voués à la
destruction pour les remettre sur le
marché et depuis quatre ans le réseau
s'est lancée dans l'activité de
dépannage réparation on répare des
appareils
nous n'avons pas vendu qui sont pas
réparées dans le cadre de la garantie ou
en dehors de la garante de nos propres
appareils et on essaie de d'assister à
cette démarche là c'est dans un premier
temps quelqu'un qui vient acheter un
appareil autant d'appareils
reconditionnés un déchet à éviter et
dans cette logique de l'économie
circulaire on l'incita à réfléchir à la
réparation de son ancien produit quand
ça me paraît judicieux on oriente vers
une première étape de réparation au
moins aller sur le diagnostic et essayer
de d'aller au bout de sa démarche et de
voir si on peut pas prolonger le un peu
plus ces appareils avant de lui proposer
un appareil de remplacement
combien même il serait un appareil
reconditionnés vertueux sur le plan
écologique
là on a beaucoup parlé du consommateur
folie pure et est-ce que ça va aussi
pousser les entreprises à proposer des
produits qui durent plus longtemps
oui je pense oui parce que il faut
pouvoir fidéliser
parce que d'abord la confiance en
appelant les commerçants clients et donc
si le bilan va se maintenir a plus de
groupe france depuis il pas confiance
viendra filmer vacances ne sait pas on
va le voir en images les appareils
seront notés sur dix du rouge au vert
c'est indices sera calculée sur cinq
critères la documentation l'engagement
du producteur à rendre disponibles les
documents techniques la démonte
habilitera bilité par démontabilité donc
la facilité à démonter et notamment les
types d'outils est nécessaire la
disponibilité des pièces détachées
le prix de ces pièces est un critère
spécifique qui sera propre à la
catégorie des produits fille pleurait à
nouveau avec vous est ce que ces
critères sont suffisants oui je pense
que c'est une sorte d'avancé parce que
ça permet quand même d'avoir une
connaissance précise de la de la qualité
de ses produits et donc que ça permet
donc aux modes d'engagement beaucoup
plus d'informations et faire des choix
judicieux par exemple arbitraire pour
les produits est également aussi se
projeter dans l'avenir
lors de la chambre sera informé de la
disponibilité ou non des pièces
détachées et parfois les pièces elle
même associée à de la main d'oeuvre
peuvent vite faire monter la note
laurence attrait ce que on pourrait
avoir un effet pervers et ce et
d'utiliser peut-être des pièces de moins
bonne qualité derrière alors moi ce qui
me dérange un petit peu dans le dans cet
indice
de répétabilité c'est qu'en fait quand
on regarde d'un peu plus près c'est une
est une auto évaluation des
constructeurs donc de fait je trouve que
c'est on va dire c'est une première
avancée c'est un 10-2 réparabilité je
pense que l''indice de durabilité sera
plus intéressant dans cinq ans on peut
effectivement c'est comme on le voit
recettes produits assez facilement dans
tout petit électroménager la qualité des
plastiques ou des pièces est quand même
assez médiocre on peut le dire on en
voit dans nos ateliers
surtout en petit électroménager et
effectivement il ya quand même une
question de qualité de matière première
aussi en fait qu'ils sont aux critiques
qui sont utilisées et qui contribue à
pérenniser en fait le produit le plus le
plus possible donc mois cet indice de
réparabilité je dis que c'est une
première avancée et c'est vraiment un
tout petit pas c'est un premier pas ce
qui peut freiner aussi on connaît tous
les téléphones portables maintenant on
ne peut plus les ouvrir on n'a plus
accès aux batteries on peut plus les
démonter est ce que on le retrouve aussi
dans le gros électroménager jean-paul
boisé est ce que maintenant on ne peut
plus ouvrir certains électroménager on
peut toujours pratiquement partout pour
venir ce qui a mystérieusement leçons
sont bloqués par des lys qui nécessitent
des litiges spéciaux on arrive toujours
à trouver une solution
la difficulté n'est fait c'est assez du
cdc outils de les construire
donc quand on est dans un atelier de
titres et par cattier moquer des outils
des tournevis spéciaux triangulaire
héros avec des formes incroyables mais
par contre l'utilisateur de base il m'a
peut être équipée lévis la difficulté
étant du négoce tic et il faut arriver à
comprendre quand il ya du palm soir mais
les promesses qu'il n'a pas d'origine
hispanique ou d'origine électronique
donc ça c'est pas gagné à tout le monde
de pouvoir servir la différence entre la
c'est pour cette la réparation le taux
réparation par le public
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
sérieusement il ya par contre avec des
ateliers pédagogiques avance et on
devrait y avoir des personnes qui
viennent
mais quel appareil à what is évoqué et
qui au point qu'il soit sur une aile
obstacles techniques soient ceux qui
n'avaient pas on arrive souvent à paris
sachant qu'on a un taux de réparation
ils ont vraiment que supérieur à 50%
dans la plupart dans des parcs est
justement vous parlez de la capacité à
réparer que ce soit au niveau des outils
voire des connaissances eric gatineau a
envie est-ce que vous avez avec 7,7
indices pendant deux réparabilité y aura
plus de formation pour vous salariés
vous allez recruter plus le sepa lundi
ça va nous faire qui va de faire évoluer
dans ce sens là je pense pas
le la montée en compétences du salarié
la formation l'accompagnement technique
et fait partie déjà de deux de nos
process et de l'orientation du
développement d'activités dépannage qui
nécessite lui
une compétence technique élevé 1 et qui
nécessitent un accompagnement différent
de l'accompagnement un atelier de nos
salariés d'un entente assertion va nous
amener à accélérer sur sur la formation
et sur la montée en compétences la
conséquence de la liste de la
réparabilité on peut le faire on peut
espérer c'est que pour les acteurs de la
réparation quels qu'ils soient des
répères café des structures comme les
nôtres ya même des professionnels
devrait nous faciliter la tâche avait
parlé des indices de démontabilité par
exemple on est confronté aujourd'hui à
des difficultés parfois taxé aux pièces
des blocs laveur thermosoudés vous avez
parfois vous devez changer intégralement
et là vous avez un rapport entre le prix
de la réparation et du tueur est
conditionné qui est déséquilibré sur le
petit électroménager beaucoup de choses
qui ont clipser se cassent facilement
des montages donc on n'est ce pas tu as
une évolution par rapport à sa part une
évaluation de ces éléments qui devrait
faciliter notre travail en atelier voilà
donc ça sera pas d'impact direct
informations ce sera ce sera quelque
chose qui devrait une facilité la tâche
et on continuera goût et à développer la
formation et les monter en compétences
de salariés mis un aspect aussi
important c'est sur la pièce détachée
avec la citation lors de la réparation a
utilisé de la pièce qui a lui même issu
de l'économie circulaire tesore emploi
et qui peut faire baisser le prix de la
réparation est vigilant vis-à-vis la
qualité mais c'est aussi une piste
intéressante aux consommateurs d'avoir
parce que hélas des tarifs plus
avantageux
justement philippe fleuret est ce que
deux côtés de l'ufc que choisir vous
allez sensibiliser vos abonnés les
personnes qui vous contactent sûr aller
jusqu'au bout l'économie circulaire et
pas des pièces neuves justement oui et
bafé est passé 25 ans en israël on perd
c'est un boxeur qui va dire
les consommateurs quel appareil
électroménager parient sur notre sur
notre site
c'est de choisir un orgue est signalé à
ce moment là le type de produit ce genre
de pannes qui le rend compte et les
difficultés qu'ils vivent à voir et cela
nous permet à ce moment là vous me
retourner soit vers divers vous serez
ensuite tout à fait ça accompagnez vous
l'avez citer tous à plusieurs reprises
au 1er janvier 2000 24 il y aura un
service de durabilité qui viendra
compléter ou remplacer peut-être cet
indice qu'il y aura des nouveaux
critères comme la fiabilité la
robustesse du produit
quelles seraient les étapes que vous
souhaiteriez tous pour aller au bout de
cette démarche et ont peut-être monsieur
gatineau en premier ce qui va falloir
regarder de près j'entendais les les
réserves de leurs ancêtres et assure sur
la façon dont les indices de
réparabilité été conçu avec avec un
risque d'être juge et partie un petit
peu dans leur conception si tu vas
falloir observer c'est déjà justement
évalué l'évaluation voit comment comment
cet indice de réparabilité et honnête
fiable et aussi quel impact il assure
sur la consommation c'est intéressant
d'observer aussi s'il a un réel impact
sur le choix du consommateur oies par le
passé une information qui était
obligatoire sur la durabilité de la
conservation des pièces détachées à
certains et révolutionner le marché de
l'électroménager
9 donc on sera attentif à cette
évolution la et après sur la peau
ce qui est intéressant c'est d'avoir des
organismes indépendants ou des organes y
voit des observateurs de contrôle comme
il choisir qui sont des positionne pour
la défense de consommateurs puissent
faire en sorte que l''indice de
durabilité oriente véritablement le
choix du consommateur et oeuvres
réellement en faveur de la progression
de la durée d'usagé apparel donc à tout
ça va dans le bon sens on est heureux
d'être constructif et optimiste
ça empêche pas d'être d'être vigilants
par rapport à la mise en place de ces à
nice c'est mon fils pleurait vous aussi
c'est que choisit repose pouce par non à
d'autres étapes dans cette lutte
oui une des premières étapes d'ailleurs
serait d'élargir la liste des ennuis
parce que la famille au début mais on
constate qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
produits qui tombe en panne
je pense par exemple aux imprimantes
amplement le marché des vides et on
constate un coupable et coûte cher
d'ailleurs à ses membres et donc on
pense à eux on peut élargir la gamme de
contenus riches en compensation
c'est un sentiment de vous partager
ben oui non parce que il ya un paradoxe
il ne fait qu' il faudrait que les
constructeurs fabriquent des appareils
qui trône en panne
et là le paradoxe il va être économique
parce que ça veut dire ce que ça mange
ou kid le soul ou économique ce qui est
des gens un peu le cas actuellement
donc si on fait des machines qui dure
une dizaine d'années ça va poser un
problème
orapi de dendrite nous l'aurons 113
laurence attrait pardon si je comprends
bien c'est aussi un changement de
comportement qu'il va falloir avoir au
moins je pense que c'est un changement
de comportement je rejoins le cet indice
de réparabilité qui doit être entre
guillemets fait manière complètement
impartial par des organismes
indépendants donc ça ça risque d'être le
plus compliqué à mettre en place parce
que effectivement les marques entre
guillemets aucun intérêt à être auditées
par des organismes extérieurs
là on est vraiment purement vendus dans
du commercial
il ya aussi lui rejoint monsieur
pleurait sur l'élargissement de plus de
2,2 du matériel concerné par cette de
réparabilité c'est clair après
effectivement ce qui nous ce qui est
important aussi c'est de quelle elle
quelle va être la valeur ajoutée ou du
petit matériel d'électroménager
c'est-à-dire un indice de réparabilité
ce qu'il va être réellement valable sur
l'appareil qui notait var euros il ya il
ya vraiment une notion de comportement
parce que effectivement un consommateur
lambda va être plus tenté de racheter un
appareil neuf parce qu on est aussi dans
une société où il faut aller vite et on
n'a pas le temps d'attendre vont donc se
passer d'un appareil à un moment donné
et être dans l'attenté d'une prochaine
réparation en fait on n'est plus du tout
habitués au niveau de nos comportements
ça donc c'est c'est compliqué en fait
c'est une grande machine qu'est en train
de se mettre en place avec plein de
différent dans un engrenage qui mis bout
à bout on perd avancé de faire avancer
mais c'est très complexe en fait
l'émission touche à sa fin je ne sais
pas si l'un de nos invités veut rajouter
quelque chose sur cet indice de
réparabilité qui les sanctions
d'ailleurs à préciser seront effectifs à
partir du 1er janvier 2022
le temps que toutes les entreprises
puisse le mettre en place juste un petit
mot juste pour pour rebondir
c'est un des enjeux des réparateurs des
structures ces deux de pouvoir donner un
accès là à la réparation il y aux
appareils rénover les réparer s'il est
facile que l'accès aux neuf ça passe par
le dj tôt ça passe par la rapidité de
service
la panne s'est toujours problématique et
il faut pouvoir répondre très vite et
très facilement à la demande et c'est
tout blanc deux atouts le challenge pour
nos structures pour pouvoir espérer
favoriser un changement de mode de
consommation
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sociétés
vous pouvez revoir cette émission sur
notre site internet ou sur notre
application mobile on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau sujet
d'actualité prenez soin de vous
[Musique]